now to the uk where a parliamentary
inquiry has
said that the government's response to
the start of the pandemic
was one of the worst public health
failures in the country's history
the report from a cross-party committee
praised the early focus on vaccinations
but
it found that the government waited too
long to implement a lockdown in early
2020 and said that led to thousands of
unnecessary deaths the report also
criticized the uk's test and traced
operation calling it
slow and chaotic
well for more let's cross over to our
correspondent berget mass in london
who's following this story
a rather damning report tell us more
about its findings
well this was a report done by sitting
members of the uk parliament and of
course the backdrop is that the uk when
you compare the country to other
european countries to other developed
countries was especially hit hard by the
pandemic
we have over 160 000 more than 160 000
people dead and also the uk has been hit
hard economically and this is basically
part of the unraveling part of the
beginning of trying to learn lessons uh
from this crisis and as you have already
said the mps they praised the vaccine
rollout so that there was
something good that they found and how
the uk has handled the crisis but
overall they say that the uk was much
too slow and they center specifically on
the beginning of the crisis they say
there was an almost fatalistic approach
to tackling kovid that mps and also the
scientific advisors of the government
seem to have thought that it's um
basically it has to run its cause and
almost a policy of of herd immunity even
though they don't specifically say that
but you could sort of draw the
conclusion that the uk government just
didn't think that they could do
something to avert this crisis and as a
result people have died unnecessarily
are there any concrete recommendations
in this report
i mean what impact is report likely to
have
well it will be and it is um very
difficult reading for for the families
of those people who have died who have
died they say that um their report was
not actually centered enough on the
victims and that it was more the
machineries of government so they were
actually really unhappy about it i think
this is in a way almost like a taster
because boris johnson has promised that
there will be a full public enquiry so a
bigger public inquiry and that's
supposed to start at the beginning of
next year so so the government
acknowledges that lessons definitely
need to be learned what about the
current situation what's the covered
pandemic right like right now in in the
uk
well kuvit is definitely still here in
the uk however we don't have the
thousands of people who are dying every
day we do still do have over 100 people
dying every day the uk government those
things that it's the vaccine that's
going to basically carry us through the
winter it's been a big uh success the
vaccine roll out and they have virtually
ended all restrictions and opening up
travel so they're really hoping that the
vaccine will basically save the uk from
now on
vegan thank you very much our
correspondent there in london berget
mass